here to talk about this and more RNC
national spokeswoman Kelly mcenany and
Arizona congressman and House Judiciary
Committee member Andy Biggs
all right congressman I'm gonna start
with you you know let's talk about this
back and forth between the the President
and Chief Justice John Roberts the
president of course continued today
talking about the fact that you know
judges are not necessarily all straight
shooters our judges partisan well judge
you know I've tried a few cases in my
time and I can tell you that that yes on
political issues I think some of them
might have a little bias and you can't
tell me that some of the judges in the
federal district court don't have an
animus against Donald J Trump and and
would wish that Hillary Clinton was
still there I you just can't nobody
believes that that stretches credulity
and quite frankly it kind of shows and
that maybe Justice Roberts is projecting
his own naivete his own bias against
bias quite frankly but you know what
really is problematic with that lace
most recent ruling is that it was a
lower court issuing once again a
national injunction against this
administration and that's that's really
problematic we've got to stop those
national in jokes and you know
congressman I'm going to get to your the
bill that you're sponsoring the bills
that you're sponsoring but I want to go
to Kelly McEnaney
you know then Kelly the truth is that
what we've got are we've got
forum-shopping on some of the biggest
issues that involve the country and in
the last segment we talked about the
fact that immigration is now for many
people the number one issue how is it
that they keep going to the ninth
circuit or courts where you know it'll
move up to the ninth circuit and then
some local I'm calling him a local
district judge gets to do a temporary
restraining order that enjoins the whole
country how does that work exactly right
yeah you have partisan hacks out there
finding the most liberal judge they can
find to then level a decision that
rebukes the power of the executive
branch the president has vast power over
immigration that was decide
and Trump versus Hawaii when the Supreme
Court literally said he has the power to
do this this was after a judge in Hawaii
unilaterally struck down the temporary
travel ban the Supreme Court of course
upheld that and now you have another
liberal activist judge doing the same
thing with this Asylum executive order
so it's forum-shopping
its activist judges and it's the
judiciary wielding power they do not
have to rebuke the illegitimate power of
the executive branch as laid out in the
Constitution of the United States and
you know with the Chief Justice getting
involved it almost is a tacit approval
for these local district court judges to
say yeah I'll enjoy in the country but
but anyway president Trump yesterday
continued his attack on the far left
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals look at
this we're getting some terrible
decisions from the Ninth Circuit as
usual and it's a shame it's a shame it's
a disgrace frankly and essentially
they're legislating they're saying what
to do some judge sitting in some
location very far away is telling our
incredible military and law enforcement
what to do and it's not right hopefully
we've shown some light on the Ninth
Circuit I know that Chief Justice
Roberts John Roberts has been speaking a
little bit about it you know I got to
tell you the congressman I mean when I
was a judge we never ever it got
involved in any way shape or form and I
said this the other night when I hosted
Hannity that it is so to me is stunning
that a Supreme Court justice will come
out and and push back at the President
of the United States you know he the
president is political Supreme Court
justice is not especially the Chief
Justice but let's talk about the the
Ninth Circuit and what we've got and and
how this circuit is you know considered
almost a circus given their decisions
right well we call it the ninth circus
here I mean it stretches from Alaska to
almost the equator it's by far the
biggest and and we can't even get an on
Bach hearing here as you know so so we
were stacked up we can't get in on bonk
hearing and then quite frankly Arizona
and
Intermountain West we're not we're not
really kind of copacetic with the with
the California mentality in the end the
coastal mentality we I have a bill to
split up the ninth circuit and we're
just we can't seem to get any action on
it partly because we have California
representatives who want their portion
of Kerry when you're out of the ninth
circuit and into the new 12th circuit
and that's really what's going on all
right Haley you know what the
congressman is proposing is splitting up
the ninth circuit which now has 29
justices the largest in the country and
I what he was referring to is the fact
in his bill that the Ninth Circuit
doesn't reflect the values of the state
that he's from and so he wants to get
out of it and I mean is that something
that we've seen done in the in the past
well the congressman is spot on I think
this is a great proposal makes a lot of
sense because the Ninth Circuit doesn't
just not represent the area over which
they rule they don't represent the
United States of America they're the
most overturned circuit for a reason I
mean it's a fact and you look at by the
way I just got to say with Justice
Roberts there where was he being vocal
when Ruth Bader Ginsberg came out
against the president and made blatantly
partisan comments that no justice has
made like that in the past where was he
rebuking when Barack Obama when after
the whole Supreme Court when he was
giving the State State of the Union but
but congressman one more thing to you
one of the arguments it would seem to me
on your behalf to split that circuit is
that there's got to be delays that
circuit has to have a lot of cases given
the huge number of states I mean you
know it's it's like it's California it's
ma in Montana it's the state of
Washington and say give me all of them
it's Arizona you can't even who can name
them all because we're talking
territories that stretch down to the
equator but but what are part of our
problems it's it's they have twice as
many cases at least that's one issue and
the other issue is think of where if
you're living in Montana if you're on
the east side of Montana and you have to
go to San Francisco to have your case
heard that's problematic and and so they
say well we're here Don we can Skype it
or something like that yeah
that's that's not real that's not real
anymore right all right thanks so much
to both of you